MARY GROVE: Great.
Good afternoon, everyone,
and welcome to our panel
discussion at Google I/O on
Lessons From Founders.
My name is Mary Grove, and I'm
the director of Google for
Entrepreneurs.
Google began as a startup in a
garage some 15 years ago, and
that spirit of entrepreneurship
is very much
a part of our DNA.
It is our team's mission to
empower the next generation of
startups to be successful
around the world.
We created Google for
Entrepreneurs specifically as
a central resource to launch
programs and partnerships to
empower entrepreneurs
around the globe.
So as a team, we focus
on two things.
The first is on building
community and fostering
entrepreneurship around
the world.
So we work with about 30
different accelerators and
incubators and co-working
spaces around the globe.
And the second thing we focus
on is on equipping
entrepreneurs with products and
technology that they need
to be successful in launching
and growing their businesses.
So we are very privileged and
lucky to work with and learn
from entrepreneurs in over 100
countries around the world.
You can learn more about
our programs at
google.com/entrepreneurs.
So today, we are very fortunate
to be joined by four
incredible startup founders and
serial entrepreneurs to
share with us their insights
and lessons that they've
learned along their journeys.
So let me please start by
introducing our panel.
First, please welcome
Slava Rubin.
Slava is the co-founder and CEO
of Indiegogo, the world's
largest global crowdfunding
platform.
Indiegogo distributes millions
of dollars across its platform
every week.
And they're really focused on
empowering individuals to
raise funds for any idea,
be it creative, be it
cause-related, or be
it entrepreneurial.
Slava recently attended the
White House signing of the
historic JOBS Act as a
representative of the
crowdfunding community, and he
also founded Music against
Myeloma, an annual charity
event to raise funds for
cancer awareness.
And we've had an opportunity to
partner closely with Slava
and his team over the last
couple years, and we're really
glad to welcome him
here today.
Next, it's my pleasure to
introduce Julia Hartz.
And Julia is the co-founder
and CEO of Eventbrite,
dedicated to democratizing
ticketing.
And they have transacted and
enabled the purchase of over
100 million tickets on the
Eventbrite platform.
Julia is focused on the
happiness and productivity and
the growth of the team at
Eventbrite, and she has
fostered a culture there that
has landed Eventbrite on the
list of the top five best places
to work in the Bay Area
for two consecutive years.
Before founding Eventbrite with
her husband Kevin, Julia
led TV development at MTV
Networks and FX Networks.
So welcome, Julia.
Next, please welcome Caterina
Fake, who is the founder and
CEO of Findery.
Findery is an augmented-reality
app which
makes places come alive
and launched in
public beta last October.
Prior to that, Caterina
co-founded Hunch, a search and
discovery engine that was
acquired by eBay in 2011.
And before that, she co-founded
the popular
photo-sharing site Flickr, which
Yahoo! acquired in 2005.
Caterina sits on the board of
Creative Commons and she
chairs the board of
directors of Etsy.
She was also named one of "Time
Magazine's" 100 most
influential people
in the world.
And please welcome
Mary Lou Jepsen.
Mary Lou is a serial
entrepreneur who has founded
or co-founded four different
startups, and she has served
as CEO or CTO, or both, for
all of them, including One
Laptop Per Child, Pixel Qi,
NY3D, and MicroDisplay Corp.
Mary Lou has really disrupted
the display industry, and she
is currently the head of the
display division at Google X.
Mary Lou has been a tenure-track
professor at MIT.
She was CTO of Intel's
display division.
She's been ranked in the top 50
female computer scientists
of all time by the Anita
Borg Institute.
And she also made "Time
Magazine's" list of 100 most
influential people
in the world.
So we are on the shoulders of
giants today, and looking
forward to a great discussion.
What we'll do is I will
kick it off with some
questions for our panel.
And in a while, we will turn
it over to the audience to
take some questions.
So start thinking
about them now.
We'll open up the floor to
questions in about 15 minutes.
So thank you all for joining
us, and welcome.
So we know today that the
web is democratizing
entrepreneurship
more than ever.
And there are new models and new
medias possible, more than
ever before.
So I'd like to start by asking
you each to spend a minute
helping us set the context.
Set the context of why now?
And for each of you, please
share the key insight with us
that really led you to develop
and disrupt the industries
that you're in, starting
with Slava.
SLAVA RUBIN: All right.
First, let me just say
it's a real honor
to be on this panel.
Just several years ago,
I went to I/O when it
was at Google campus.
And just to be here is
incredible, and obviously,
incredible panelists.
Indiegogo was from 2006.
There's two co-founders and
I, we got together.
Eric, Danae, and I were
overlooking the Golden Gate
Bridge and we were sharing
experiences of how frustrated
we are to try to use the
internet to raise money.
So if you could just go back
seven years to 2006, you have,
YouTube is not owned
by Google yet.
Twitter is nascent.
You have MySpace is way
bigger than Facebook.
And Obama is not a word
for most people.
And it was really difficult to
raise money using MySpace,
essentially, and Paypal.
And my dad died of cancer when
I was 15, and then 10 years
later, I decided to do something
about it for a New
Year's resolution, so
I started a charity.
And I wanted to use the
internet, because I thought I
was a little tech-savvy.
And it was very difficult.
Eric was on the board of a
theater company and he was
trying to raise money.
And Danae was working with
different filmmakers and
entrepreneurs.
We thought, huh, YouTube is
doing something interesting in
the media space, and there's
other companies that are
disrupting other spaces, like
eBay, and Prosper was new.
Why is it that the ultimate
democratization tool hasn't
really created access to
capital for anyone?
It is still all a gated
experience.
So we were actually completely
naive, and had not been
entrepreneurs before.
And we launched in
January 2008.
I would say that there's a lot
of myths out there as to how
you need to become an
entrepreneur, whether it is
you need to have a lot of
money to start off with.
Whether it is that you need to
have a perfect marketing plan.
You need to have a really
good business plan.
You need to have done
a lot of research.
I think the barriers to entry
are so low that you could so
quickly be able to identify
whether or not you could gain
traction and move fast in
whatever direction you can go,
based on data.
And that is something that 20
years ago, you used a business
plan to get that feedback.
Hey, professor, what do you
think of my business plan?
Then give me feedback.
Now you can actually very
quickly use your business plan
online, which is actually just
right away getting validation
from the market.
A perfect example of that, and
I'll end here, is we just
actually had--
the company that got second
place at CES for most
innovative new product was
founded on Indiegogo, the
Misfit Shine.
And they raised nearly
$1 million and
this was just an idea.
And it was an idea that
VCs weren't sure if
they wanted to fund.
And it's just so interesting
now, how it's becoming very
validated and it's going
out to the market.
And we balanced that with things
like the first ever
crowd-funded baby.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
SLAVA RUBIN: The couple was not
able to get insurance as
needed, and they were able to
get the in vitro fertilization
funded through the public.
Or you have Oscar award-winners
from just this
last February.
So I think it's a great time
to really press forward and
have other thoughts.
JULIA HARTZ: Wow, I wish I would
have thought about that,
crowdfunded baby.
Could you do that retroactively,
or no?
SLAVA RUBIN: What's that?
JULIA HARTZ: Can you do that
retroactively, or?
SLAVA RUBIN: You could try.
JULIA HARTZ: So I'm the
co-founder and president of
Eventbrite, and I started
Eventbrite with my now
husband, who was my fiance,
and our third co-founder,
Renaud Visage.
And I wanted to echo some of the
sentiments that Slava had
about what you need
to get started.
And I think that what we did
in the beginning was we
started with the notion that
we really did want to
democratize an industry by
harnessing the power of
technology.
And I think that what
we thought about
back then, in 2007--
which seems like so long ago--
was that everybody was thinking
about the future and
about the proliferation of our
online world, and how we'd be
living in a more
virtual world.
And over the course of a few
years, that our entire world
would be completely online, and
that we would move farther
and farther away from personal
relationships.
And our thesis was that
actually, you could use
technology and the social graph,
really, to bring people
together offline easier.
And I think what we've seen
happen is just that.
I think that going back to those
early days, the three of
us, we bootstrapped
the company.
We didn't need many resources
to test this theory out.
We needed a community that liked
to get together, which
just so happened to be the tech
community, of all places.
And we needed to build
a great product.
And so we are very heads-down on
what mattered to us, which
was truly just the product
and our customer.
And it was like that
for four years.
And I think that when I look
back at when we did actually
end up raising money, we knew
a lot about ourselves.
And we also knew a lot about
what was happening in the tech
world, what was happening with
social, what was happening
with mobile, what was on
the horizon for data.
And that helped us understand
how powerful this product that
we had built could be.
And it helped us, obviously,
raise money quite quickly at
that point.
And so from a very small germ
of an idea and, really, no
money, we are able to set
our own pace and test
this theory over time.
And I think what comes to mind
today is when you think about
how you spend your time--
whether it be at a conference
like Google I/O, or at a
festival, or running
an obstacle race--
those offline experiences are
incredibly powerful, because
those are indelible memories.
And while we're capturing
memories on our Google
Glasses, those are the types
of things at these offline
experiences that you're never
going to quite forget as
easily as a newsfeed article
that you read.
And so I think we're really
understanding the power of the
live experience, which
hopefully, you guys are all
experiencing today.
CATERINA FAKE: Is this on?
Ah, now it is.
I'm very jealous of the
four-year, is it, kind of
startup path.
I've tried to do that, but I
always went broke before the
four years were out.
I'm in many ways an accidental
entrepreneur.
I am someone who always loved
computers, but I was an
English major, and I studied
art, and I was interested in
other things.
But one thing I think is common
to me and probably
everybody on this panel and any
entrepreneurs in the room
is that you are the kind
of person that sees the
possibility in things.
And you can't help but, when
you're out in the world, see
things that need fixing, or
problems that need solving, or
ways that you could help.
And also a sense that you
could build this thing.
That you could make
this thing.
That if you just kind of sit
down at your computer and
start coding, you can actually
build something that can
change the lives of people.
And this is, I think, kind of
where the impulse comes from.
And until I was in my mid-30s,
I didn't self-identify as an
entrepreneur.
And yet if I looked at all of
the things that I had done, I
was always a starter.
I was always kind of a person
who just developed things in
my spare time and just hacked
on stuff at night and on
weekends, when I
wasn't at work.
And that is, I think,
where the strong
tendency has come from.
In all of the companies that
I've built, including my
current one, my last one, the
first one, all of them--
the ones that nobody's even
heard about and the ones that
failed miserably or were lost
in the sands of time--
those kind of came from that
same general impulse.
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Why now?
I just started a new effort at
Google X, and I can't talk
much about it.
By why now, there, is there's
in some sense, at Google X,
it's a bit like the hardware
division of Google.
And there's no more silicon
in Silicon Valley.
It's all iPhone apps
and whatever.
Nexus apps, and so forth.
[LAUGHTER]
But I love hardware.
I loved flashing colored lights
as a kid, and I just
kept going with that.
So I did a lot of art in
electrical engineering and
optics and things like that.
So that, for me, came together
in displays.
And I used to make really,
really expensive things,
one-of-a-kind things.
Designed a system to project
video on the moon for all of
humanity to see.
And I decided, wow,
democratization, this stuff
was happening about 10 years
ago in cellular technology.
And I thought, how do we get
data to all the people of the
world, not just the
rich people?
So I was lucky enough to meet
Nicholas Negroponte and start
One Laptop Per Child with him.
And I became a--
I hadn't designed a laptop
before, but I designed the
$100 laptop.
And I got in an access to fabs
that nobody got access to at
the level that I did.
And I decided to start my next
company-- again, I just always
think, well, we're alive.
How do we use the
time the best?
What can I do today?
And what's the sort of imprint,
the impact, that I
can contribute to?
So I started a company in 2008
called Pixel Qi, given the
access I've gotten, in a pretty
broken part of the
hardware industry, which is
the display industry.
Which runs on and off between
zero and negative 20% margin,
and has slashed pretty much all
R&D for the last 10 years.
So we're one of the few
organizations that's done some
innovative R&D in the
display industry.
And it's my belief that the
devices that we use, from the
smallest to the largest, are
pretty much, if you look from
a cost structure, a use
structure, and a power
structure , screens, given
the cloud has happened.
And so now, because it's
completely broken, the funding
models are completely
screwed up.
VCs used to have 30,
40 X routine.
Now they struggle with
one X routine.
Angel funding isn't sufficient
for hardware.
And I thought, roll up my
sleeves, figure it out.
So I moved to Asia and
learned Chinese
and was pretty effective.
But now I'm back in the Bay
Area, working for Sergey.
MARY GROVE: So great.
Thank you.
Just curious, a quick
show of hands.
How many entrepreneurs
in the room today?
About 50%.
How many aspiring
entrepreneurs?
Great, great.
Well, thanks for joining us.
So I'm going to turn quickly--
we often speak about the
importance of team, and how
that's just the most
fundamental part of a startup.
Julia, I'd love to ask you some
of your learnings and
experiences from building and
growing a team at Eventbrite
and fostering the culture
that has been clearly so
meaningful.
JULIA HARTZ: Well, first and
foremost, I can't stress
enough-- especially since I
married to him-- on how
important it is to find
the right partner.
I think that what we've
realized in building a
co-foundership while also being
married, we have to be
quite careful about where we
draw the lines and how we
divide and conquer.
But in hindsight now, seven
years later, I look back and
understand that this is a lesson
that all co-founders
should learn.
And that it starts with finding
the right partners.
And maybe they're not your
co-founders, but they're the
second people in line to you.
They're the people that rally
around your idea.
But those people should have
your best interests at heart,
or the best interest of what's
most important to you.
And also, they should have
complementary skills.
I think that the fact that Kevin
and I, our skills really
don't overlap, is such a
great advantage for us.
Because we're able to have this
incredible air cover now,
over a company that's 250 people
large, and that we
operate together on a
day-to-day basis.
And when I think about how lucky
we are to make all that
work, I truly feel fortunate.
But I also think that there's
some really specific lessons
in there for all co-founders.
And then team.
I mean, we have 21 minutes
and 15 seconds.
I could go on and
on about team.
But I think that when you get
to the point where you start
having people come on board,
you have to remember and be
humbled by the fact that they're
giving up their career
and livelihoods for your idea.
That they're putting their--
not giving up, I guess,
but they're putting
their careers at risk.
And I look around the
room every day and
I think about that.
And it humbles me, because I
think there's something so
powerful about being able to
get somebody excited about
your vision.
And it still very much
feels like our vision
is just this idea.
And it's sort of this
harebrained idea, and I can't
believe that so many people
would believe in that idea,
and come and sit alongside us
and fight the battles that
we're fighting with us.
And so I think coming from that
humble perspective of
understanding how incredible
it is to be able to build a
team is, I think, a really
good starting point.
And then I think when you have
those teams, making sure that
each person on your team can
fully understand how their
work impacts your vision, and
that your vision is crystal
clear and it's compelling--
those are some of the most
important things you need to
do on a constant,
constant basis.
I'm constantly reiterating our
vision and making sure that
every single person in the
room understands how they
directly impact that vision.
And we're at 250.
I don't know what's next, in
terms of how we scale.
Some of you may be able
to tell me that.
But I still know the first and
last name of every single
person on the team, and what
they do, and how that impacts
the vision.
So there's that ability to stay
connected to your team
that I think means all
the world to them.
MARY GROVE: Thank you.
Great.
Mary Lou, a product
question for you.
I am just fascinated by the
way you have been able to
dramatically disrupt the
display industry--
slashing power consumption,
slashing the cost.
Talk to us about the process
of bringing an idea into
product, specifically physical
product form.
And what lessons have you
learned in the various
iterations of display that
enable you do the work that
you do today?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: It's
interesting, because these
days, the manufacturing is
controlled by a small number
of countries, primarily Taiwan
and South Korea.
And so you need to figure out
how to deal with cultures,
learn the languages,
and so forth.
But in many ways, it's freed
me for the last decade,
because I don't really actually
have to worry about
manufacturing problems,
yield reliability.
Because basically, all I have to
do is get a whole bunch of
people to say yes because
they have my back.
And if I can get about 100
people in the various fabs to
say yes-- they say no 99% of
the time, but you work and
noodle through.
And so the industry has changed
so much since when I
started, when we built our own
manufacturing facilities, till
now that the problem--
I've sat on a bunch of startup
panels over the past year, and
I've noticed a rise of the
multinational startup.
And it's hard--
15 time zones and languages--
but there's these huge
advantages in doing that if
you can navigate the
cultural things.
So the product stuff is sort of
more cultural, and how to
get people to come together in
various, if you will, axes of
creativity--
Asia's creative in that they
create a million units a day
of something.
And maybe they're not sort of,
in some Silicon Valley terms,
swinging for the fences in an
innovative architecture.
But boy, can you combine those
two axes and the sensibility
around these things, process
windows, and yields, and
[INAUDIBLE], all of that
has to work on
any product you make.
But a lot of the engineers there
have never been allowed
to get in the lab and break
things, and not do what I say,
like violate what I say.
And sort of creating--
it comes back to team and
creating these cultures where
you can create these hybrids.
And take these super-creative
people and get them good on
both axes, really.
It's never a single
individual.
It's creating the
team to do that.
MARY GROVE: Caterina, you have
built three successful
consumer technologies, had
two phenomenal exits.
Can you talk with us about the
process of exit and the
different factors and
consideration in your mind,
and how you navigated that?
CATERINA FAKE: Well, exits--
exits are--
exits--
there's always kind of a lot
of stories behind the exits
that are not visible
or understood.
So to kind of go back
to Flickr, which
was acquired by Yahoo!
In 2005, Flickr came out of
a company that had failed.
We had started a company
to build a game.
And we had started it in 2002,
which if you recall, was a
terrible time to raise
capital for anything.
Especially a consumer
internet play.
And we were also trying to do
something that people didn't
really understand.
We were building a browser-based
game.
It was a massively multiplayer
role playing game.
It was somewhat quirky.
It was a bit odd.
And it was not understood
what the hell it was.
People were like, can you buy
it on the shelf at CompUSA?
Like what is this thing?
And the only things that you
played in your browser at the
time were Solitaire
and casual games.
And so it would be kind of
like an exaggeration--
I mean, it would be an
understatement to say really
that we had trouble
raising money.
We were unable to
raise any money.
We prevailed upon our friends
and family, who finally gave
us, we managed to scrape
together $150,000, $200,000 to
actually run our company.
But nobody was getting paid.
And it really kind of struck
me when Julia was talking
about the team, that here
are all these people.
Not only were the Flickr team
members along for this crazy
ride, but most of us weren't
getting paid.
So it was a bit nuts.
And to get up every morning--
the only guy that was getting
paid was the guy who
had three kids.
So if you want to survive
in this industry.
It's actually been proven
to be the case.
Like in the Donner Party, only
the single men were eaten.
[LAUGHTER]
CATERINA FAKE: Get married
and have children
as fast as you can.
So anyway, the only guy who was
getting paid was the guy
who had three children.
Survival, people.
This is what it's about.
Like the startup businesses
is like, do or die.
It's like a revolution.
You're like, you win
or you're dead.
[LAUGHTER]
And this was kind
of like that.
So we were dying.
We had about three months of
money left in the bank.
We were eating ramen
and selling our
furniture to make payroll.
And then we said, to
hell with this.
This is going to fail.
This game is doomed.
And we gotta do something
else.
We only have three months of
money left to pay our one guy.
So Stewart has this idea.
He's like, photo-sharing.
He wakes up in the middle
of the night.
He's like literally got
103-degree fever.
I was married to him at the
time, so this is why we're
waking up together, with
my co-founder.
And he's like, we should do
a photo-sharing site.
And I'm like, you're--
whatever.
Drink some water.
Go back to bed.
And so we talked about it a
little bit more, and we
figured, OK, well, there's a lot
of things that we learned
from the social aspects
of our game.
We can put this together.
We can make a thing.
We spent about eight weeks
developing this thing.
We called it Flickr.
It was a chat where you could
drag and drop photos into a
conversation.
It was actually a POS, but it
was widely noticed, actually.
Because if you recall back at
the time-- it was like 2003--
social networking was on the
rise, and people thought this
was cool and this
was like social
networking around photos.
And so we kind of had hit
it, and we kind of
knew we'd hit it.
Because suddenly we were getting
calls and people were
interested in us, and we were
six unknown people in
Vancouver, and nobody
would return-- so it
was kind of a thing.
Anyway, we were talking
about exits.
[LAUGHTER]
MARY GROVE: So many great
insights I just
took away from there.
Have children.
Great ideas come from a fever.
CATERINA FAKE: So this was the
pivot, and then it was
successful.
And then we got a call from
bunch of acquirers.
And then we were acquired.
MARY GROVE: Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
CATERINA FAKE: Just
to wrap up.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
MARY GROVE: So amazing.
CATERINA FAKE: Sorry.
MARY GROVE: In just a couple
minutes, we'll start taking
questions from the audience.
So I encourage you, if you
have a question in mind,
please go ahead and start
lining up at the two
microphones here.
So next question is for Slava,
and it's more of a
policy-related question.
I'm really intrigued by your
work with the JOBS Act and
representing the crowdfunding
community.
So please talk with us about
the role that founders and
entrepreneurs can play in
advancing the conversation
forward around tech policy.
SLAVA RUBIN: Yeah, so I'll take
a little bit of a windy
road there.
It was interesting, when they
asked about, how many of you
are entrepreneurs, how many
of you raised your hands.
I don't know if you would change
your question if the
question was, how many of
you are entrepreneurial?
I actually think probably more
of you are entrepreneurs than
raised your hands.
See, in our perspective of it,
yes entrepreneur might mean to
actually have started the
business or whatever.
But we recruit mostly
entrepreneurs.
It's actually quite challenging,
in terms of when
you want to be collaborative
and authentic and all that.
But see, there's certain types
of people who say, oh, I
didn't get to do that
because there wasn't
enough this, right?
I didn't have enough
money, enough time.
That person didn't let me.
We couldn't partner
with that company.
And there's certain types of
people that say, I got to
figure it out this way.
And the people who don't take
no for an answer and don't
really care what the obstacle
is in front of them are
entrepreneurs.
That's the spirit of the
entrepreneur, which is, "See
wall, run through it." But
actually fail five times, so
get your head hurt
really hard.
Right?
That's entrepreneur.
And in my opinion--
you're getting into a pet
project, which is
entrepreneurs can
save the world.
Which is entrepreneurs
will figure out the
solution to any problem.
And it's really just a language
that hasn't been
fostered enough.
Which is, it's obvious that
we should learn math, OK?
It became obvious that
we should learn
languages beyond English.
Cool.
Now it's become obvious
that we should
all learn code, right?
So you have code.org.
You have Chicago starting to
teach code into every high
school, all this good stuff.
It's just a matter of time
before it becomes obvious that
teaching, in an experiential
way, entrepreneurship should
be part of your curriculum
from seventh grade, third
grade, or whatever grade.
And I've written stuff
about this.
Which is kind of sad, in my
opinion, that when you're a
little kid in kindergarten, and
you have those little toys
that you play with, you get to
play with fireman or woman.
You get to play with nurse.
You get to play with
lawyer, doctor.
You don't get to play
with entrepreneur.
[LAUGHTER]
SLAVA RUBIN: And it might be
because it's really hard to
say entrepreneur.
So we could just call
it Google, whatever.
[LAUGHTER]
SLAVA RUBIN: But really, that's
a statement as to how
we grow up.
And it's funny, because when
we graduate high school or
college, we're all told to be
innovative and leaders and all
this stuff.
But really, what we're prepared
to do is to become
bankers or developers or
consultants or whatever you
want to call it inside somebody
else's organization,
which is inside of a system that
somebody else created.
Why isn't it that we are being
taught to be able to take
risk, be creative, fail--
it's totally good to fail.
We just have to learn that.
Learn from it.
So for me, the idea of whether
it's equity crowdfunding,
which is where Indiegogo has
had a lot of participation
with the SEC and the White
House and all that stuff.
But also in terms of
empowering more
entrepreneurs-- if you get off
on the sixth floor of our
office, which is at 965 Mission,
which is right on the
corner, the first word you'll
see is a huge sign of the word
"Empower."
I mean, that is Indiegogo.
Which is to empower people
to do what they
didn't think is possible.
See, if you empower an
entrepreneur to do something,
you could change the trajectory
of the future.
There could have an air there
yesterday, and an entrepreneur
will create reality.
So it's just fascinating.
So I think more of you should
have raised your hands.
MARY GROVE: Great, great.
[APPLAUSE]
MARY GROVE: We're going to do
some rapid-fire questions, so
we'll try to do one minute each
question, if possible.
Please.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Kent Nixon,
and I guess this is a question
for all of you, but specifically
for Mary Lou.
Because I'm a computer
engineer, and
my passion is hardware.
And I agree with what you're
saying, a lot of the stuff out
there nowadays is software
as opposed to hardware.
But when I look at a piece of
hardware, I can say, wow,
that's really great, but.
And there's always that but.
And I think I can make it
better, but I have a specific
set of skills, and it takes more
than just me to make a
great product.
I mean, how do you go about
finding people that meet the
skill sets that you
don't have?
How do you go about even making
the contacts to learn
about that kind of stuff?
Like where would you even
start, basically?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Yeah,
interesting.
Because there's not
a lot of hardware.
You know, IEEE has a ton of
meetings every week, here in
the Bay Area, if you're
in the Bay Area.
But actually, OLPC, One Laptop
Per Child, $100 laptop?
It was a really small
hardware team.
It was just me for the first 18
months, and then we grew to
the massive size of, I think,
four hardware engineers that
were actually at OLPC.
And used kind of Asia, Inc. and
the people that I was able
to create a team around, we
were sort of dotted-line
architects for groups of
low-level engineers in Asia.
It means living on a plane.
If you love it enough, you're
willing to do that.
It means learning the various
languages and so forth.
But it depends the scale of
what you're trying to do.
And if you're saying, yes,
I like that, but--
you could join that team
or take it apart.
It's hard, because you can hack
different things, but it
tends to be a big thing
hanging-- you know, a
functional tethered prototype.
And it's really hard
for a VC to get--
VCs, actually, they don't have
the core competence anymore in
Silicon Valley, pretty
much, to--
and I'm sure there's
exceptions.
But by and large, to
fund or even to do
diligence on hardware.
But there are places that do
fund hardware, and you can
find them, depending
upon your bent.
You do have to be creative.
There are angels, certainly, and
super angels to fund it.
And there are the hackerspaces
if you need to borrow an
oscilloscope for whatever,
and SEM.
But yeah, it's not easy.
But then again, there's not
this sort of path--
there's not much competition.
So there's an advantage.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so this is
[INAUDIBLE] from China.
So actually, I have a question,
but not specific to
any of you guys.
And so my question is, because
we can find a lot of common
factor for successful
founders.
And so I want to know, what is
your rating for the below
three factors?
They are vision, idea,
and execution.
So how can you rate these three
factors, and what's the
reason for that?
MARY GROVE: Julia?
JULIA HARTZ: I'm trying to
understand the question.
MARY GROVE: So vision--
JULIA HARTZ: Like how would
I rate mission?
AUDIENCE: Vision, idea,
and execution.
JULIA HARTZ: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I would rate--
if I had a stack rank them?
AUDIENCE: From like 0
to 10, or 1 to 10?
[LAUGHTER]
JULIA HARTZ: I'm shooting
in the dark, here.
I'll try to understand
the question.
I think that vision is really
important when you're trying
to lead a group of people.
I think execution is how you get
from point A to point B,
as Caterina can attest
to, as can we.
And how you eventually
get people to
believe in your idea.
But you don't really
start doing
anything without the idea.
So I think they're all
intrinsically linked, and so
I'm not sure if I
would rank them.
But I think that as
an entrepreneur--
I don't necessarily think you
have be the person who can
sell the vision.
I think you have to do what
Slava said, which is, be
willing to run through as
many walls as possible.
I, too, agree with him, in terms
of that's what makes an
entrepreneur an entrepreneur, is
just that eternal optimism.
But I think that having that
idea and having that moment
that Stewart had, when he woke
up in the middle the night, is
exactly what goes into
this mixture.
And then vision is something
that really matters when
you're trying to get people
to sign on to your idea.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because
nowadays, also, we just feel
like ideas, we have a
lot of same ideas.
But no one just go ahead
and execute them.
So probably execution is one of
the most important when you
have the idea.
JULIA HARTZ: Well, I mean,
that's how you make the idea
into a reality.
You have to execute.
And honestly, like day to day,
we're put to the task of
executing, even seven years
into our vision, I guess.
If you're not executing, then
you really aren't able to grow
a viable idea into a company and
get people to support you.
So yeah, I think they're all
incredibly important.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SLAVA RUBIN: I would say that
"idea is super important" is
one of the ten myths of
entrepreneurship.
Meaning, it's not.
If it was so big of an idea, if
it mattered so much, then
the idea of a coffee shop would
not become Starbucks.
Obviously, other people know
that idea as well.
So it's really about
execution.
AUDIENCE: Mm-hm.
Thank you.
MARY GROVE: Thank you.
We have time for one
more question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] touched on
this a little bit, but I'm
hoping someone else will
volunteer to chime in.
And my question is, how did
you find your co-founder?
And how did you know they
were the right person?
Or did you?
SLAVA RUBIN: Match.com, right?
[LAUGHTER]
MARY GROVE: A wedding.
JULIA HARTZ: I met
him at a wedding.
[LAUGHTER]
SLAVA RUBIN: So my co-founders
were--
there's two co-founders.
One was the technical guy.
So he and I worked at
the same consulting
firm for eight years.
We're best friends.
We used to live together.
He was on the tech side.
So he had to round out his skill
set, he thought, so to
go get his MBA.
So he went to Haas to get his
MBA while I kept on working.
And like anybody who keeps on
working who has a friend
that's getting their MBA, you go
visit them for the weekend
to get drunk for the weekend.
And anybody who goes to get
their MBA, they have to start
a business, so they have to
start coming up with ideas.
So he met his co-founder,
which is Danae, his
friend at the time.
Danae and I flew out for dinner,
and we were all just
talking about stuff.
And the idea was born.
MARY GROVE: So I'd like to ask
each of our panelists to share
with our entrepreneurial
audience just one piece of
parting advice.
In no particular order.
CATERINA FAKE: Well, I think the
main thing, as Slava was
saying earlier, is it's
very easy to do
startups these days.
So just really start.
Start from where you are
with what you have.
If you don't have a co-founder,
start without a
co-founder.
I think a lot of time--
it's interesting.
A get a lot of emails from
entrepreneurs, asking, I need
a co-founder.
I can't find a co-founder.
How do I found a co-founder.
That is actually a huge issue.
Go to more weddings,
is one possibility.
I mean, actually, you
know, whatever.
Luck favors the aggressive.
So you should go meet as
many people as you can.
It's easier if you're
an extrovert.
If you're an introvert,
just go to
everything and talk to everybody.
And find that co-founder
out there.
But really, just start
making the thing
that you want to make.
If you can only do it with
a piece of paper and
a pencil, do that.
It'll come together.
In fact, I'm an investor
in Kickstarter.
It's a competitor of Slava's.
And I actually saw it when it
was just a Photoshop file.
It was actually just-- it was
an image in Photoshop.
I was like, I see this.
SLAVA RUBIN: Yeah,
I think that--
you know how sometimes people
tell you, oh, that's hot.
Don't touch it.
Yet you still kind of
need to touch it?
And you figure out that it was
hot, hotter than you thought?
That your tolerance for heat
was not higher than their
tolerance for heat?
[LAUGHTER]
It's interesting that you know
what I'm talking about, right?
Because most of you have
probably done that.
But see, here is the same thing
at a different level.
There's a macrosocial contract
of what it means to be able to
break through something or
not as an entrepreneur.
So we fall within these rules
of, your idea is not big
enough, because a VC told you.
There's things like--
it's, I don't know
marketing enough.
I don't know PR enough.
Right?
There's all these different
macrosocial contract concepts,
which is the same thing as if
somebody told you it's hot.
Yet you were all daring
enough to touch
the kettle, the whatever.
You should just experience it
yourself, and then learn for
yourself your own truths.
Because I dare you-- you
will that most of
those are just fiction.
They're somebody else's truths
that they could not break
through that.
Right?
So there's no reason that you
would not be able to.
[APPLAUSE]
MARY LOU JEPSEN: My advice is,
assuming that you start big
and swing for the fences, and
just don't do-- don't do
something small, first off.
But assuming you do, and you get
to that point where you're
taking on one of the largest
companies in the world, even
though you didn't mean to--
I've never started to mean to.
Be prepared to give away most
of your stock so you
can win that game.
Because otherwise,
you're crushed.
And just plan that early
on, what you're going
to do if you happen--
at One Laptop Per Child, I think
there was a "60 Minutes"
expose on some of
the large forces
that we came up against.
And a lot of the stories
I haven't yet
told about Pixel Qi.
But when you do get in that
seat, you have to be able to
figure out a way where it's
more attractive for those
companies not to crush you.
And that's very difficult.
And if you can plan for success
at the start, maybe
you can sort of navigate
through.
That's, I think, the most
difficult challenges I've
faced in my career.
And the other thing is,
why do startups?
If you just join a big
company, I mean--
I'm really bad at politics.
I think if you do your own
thing, you can actually,
you're all in a little
lifeboat.
There might be leaks in it.
But you get to be out on the
sea yourself and figure out
your own way and learn all
the different things.
And then maybe you can start to
sort of leverage the sharp
elbows in larger companies.
Some people are better at it,
but if you're not one for the
politics of large companies,
startups are great.
Because everybody's in the same
boat, willing to help
each other.
They're really fantastic
environments.
So go for it.
JULIA HARTZ: The biggest lesson
that I've learned along
this journey-- and it was a
pretty big one for me, coming
from traditional media-- is
don't believe the hype.
And I think I touch on that
almost weekly when I think
about what's important to us.
And hype is a fairly vague term
as I'm using it, which is
either bad hype, the way Slava
was just presenting, that you
can't do something.
You don't have enough
experience, or there isn't
money in X, or this idea's
too played out.
And it's also on the flip side,
that god, things are
going great.
I'm great.
I must be great.
This is great.
There's one thing about having
confidence in yourself.
There's the other thing in
always looking at the next
thing you need to be doing to
making your product better,
making your team batter, to
making your brand better.
And it's not about--
if all you care about is the
hype and all you're seeking is
the hype, there's very
little context.
Or there's nothing really
underneath that.
And that's where I tend
to see things go awry.
So try not to believe
the hype, whether
it be good or bad.
MARY GROVE: Great.
Well, three words that we've
heard consistently throughout
our discussion are
democratization, passion, and
change the world.
And we truly believe that
entrepreneurs have
transformative ability to change
their communities,
their companies, the world.
And that when entrepreneurs
succeed, all boats rise.
So, really appreciate all
four of your time.
Wish you the best of luck, and
wish all of you in the
audience the best
of luck, too.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]